we need to understand that that these
aren't just like helpful AI systems that
are gonna drive us around and all of
that I mean there's a lot more going on
there and they could become benevolent
or malevolent and it's up to us right
now and it is a hell of a lot of
responsibility and I'm not sure we're
doing a very good job boom what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don sake on we are in the beautiful
Cambridge Massachusetts we are now going
to be talking about talking to robots
we have David Ewing Duncan joining us on
the show hello hi Alan thank you so much
for coming on again David thank you and
this is our third episode with you which
is awesome you were our second episode
ever and then again we did it at arc
fusion and here we are talking about
your newest book talking to robots
David Ewing Duncan has authored 10 books
and 500 plus articles on the subjects of
bioscience technology in the
implications for Humanity
his most recent book talking to robots
explores tales from our human robot
futures and this is at a time when
robotics and artificial intelligence are
at their nascent stages of permeating
into every aspect of our lives what will
it look like when robot physicians are
democratized when we turn to robots for
sex and intimacy and when robots
obsolete tedious jobs optimize our
education run our politics and help us
uncover the secrets of the universe
these transitory periods are so
interesting and you write about it in
great depth here I loved reading this
book it's coming out July 16th right and
that link is below check out David's
website link for details as well as the
links below David let's jump into
talking about why you chose to write
this book well I spent most of my career
you know as you said writing about
technology which is really interesting
especially biotech with synthetic
biology and genetics and all these other
things but what does it mean for us as
humans and what does it mean for the
planet what does it even mean for the
universe that's what fascinates me so
what does it mean
what does it mean for our kids you know
our parents so this became a vehicle it
was actually moving out of its I mean
it's not all about bio but it is all
about technology and this extraordinary
moment that that we're in right now so
they're 24 robots in here and there
could be 200 I mean it's pretty much you
know only limited by your imagination
but as you said there's sexbots warrior
BOTS dock BOTS there's a god bot which
we can talk about it's not the guy with
the beard it's actually something else
but so each one of these robots is being
either built right now or is being
thought about and so each of the
chapters has a real person that I
interviewed like say Kevin Kelly or
Brian Green or
one Enrique is or Rodrigo Martinez and I
asked them what kind of robot they would
like to meet in the future or they would
be afraid to meet and so we have these
incredible discussions and that forms
the basis of it and I did some reporting
around what's happening like safe
autonomous warfare you know and all of
that is factual and nonfiction but I
want to know how it's going to turn out
so the other part of each of these
chapters is fictional so everything is
told from the future by a narrator that
we you know is not identified but he or
she or it may be it's a robot they know
how it turned out in the future and
there are various futures so it's
scenarios where everything turns out
great and scenarios where it does not
turn out so well and at the very end we
go thirteen and a half billion years
into the future when the universe is
beginning to implode on itself so that's
how far ahead we go so it's nonfiction
kind of wrapped by a fictional story and
I love how you're you're making this
really clear that we're in this
transitionary period that we already see
robots permeating into so many parts of
our existence and we have these
different stories about how we're
experiencing this and I actually a lot
of the book emotionally resonated with
me because it's everything from the
Teddy bought with the young child all
the way up to the physician bot for the
adults the sexy man - Missy bot and so I
want us to unpack some of these examples
so the what you write about with the
Teddy bot this it starts with even the
children are exposed to robots at the
youngest of ages well I don't know a lot
kids carry around a robot basically an
AI system which is their their
smartphone and so it you know we we are
in what I call the e re the early robot
era and being early there's still a lot
to come that's one of the reasons I
wanted to talk about the future but much
of this is already here and Teddy bot is
fascinating that was actually Kevin
Kelly's idea you know the futurist and I
was surprised I mean I mean some cases I
had no idea what these people were gonna
come up with but we have this discussion
and Teddy bought it literally in the
future every every parent wants to buy
their kid a teddy bot and it takes care
of them it's a teacher it you know it
keeps them safe it's like a you know a
babysitter a lifeguard
you know teacher all rolled into one and
they're incredibly smart and and
probably send [ __ ] so then then we run
into some themes that run throughout the
book which is another reason I wrote the
book because following technology all
these years they're patterns so
everybody loves the Teddy bots when it
comes out these kids are I mean you know
it's more than even a real stuffed
animal that every kid or a blankie or
something that kids have and the parents
love it because they trust it and but
then you know a few troubling things
begin to happen like who programs
morality into this little teddy bot and
if you're you know as Kevin Kelly said I
don't know if you're like a right wing
you know political person do you program
it for that to be super ultra
conservative or as he said if you live
in Marin County you know good you know
he's in San Francisco or everybody is
super liberal and progressive do you
programa for that do you trust the
corporation that makes it the program it
you know is there like some kind of
regulations so the government comes up
with when a teddy BOD gets this
secret from the child and then tells the
parents yeah well then there's yeah
there's a parental control panel of
course and the little kid is telling all
his secrets too because that's what you
know we all had that some little teddy
teddy bear some who we whispered our
secrets to right as our imaginary friend
so this is a real imaginary friend
except it's not imaginary but all of
those secrets go to the parents in the
story and when the kid finds out they
feel betrayed by Teddy BOTS so they kind
of put Teddy bot away but they really
miss Teddy BOTS so they bring it back
and Teddy BOTS teaches them how to
deprogram the parental can maybe the
control panel so then the betrayal is
switched to the parents and they love
Teddy BOTS again and these are the
examples from the younger years I think
the ones that are already just so much
in our world are related to one of the
most primordial instincts of sex and
intimacy yeah so you walk us through the
sex pot well just could have finished
the arc which is for Teddy Poppins for
all the other chatter of many of the
chapters yes we go through this love
period of like our phones we've already
done this I mean I don't know I mean we
could do this almost any technology but
then we discover that you know
technology is always a double-edged
sword and they're great things if
they're used intelligently they can be
disastrous if they're not and so we
discover like we're doing it with social
media right now I mean there's a lot of
downsides that turns out to something
that we all love them the first came out
you know Facebook Twitter everything
then we're in a period now in fact with
social media like what do we do with it
do we regulate it do we you know break
it up you should Google be several
companies I mean all these issues which
has happened before so that's why it's
fun to trap late into the future because
that will happen with all of these
technologies in some cases it already is
and there's sometimes disaster happens
sometimes we do figure it out so anyway
there's sex and intimacy bought and by
the way it started out yeah I call it a
sex pot because there are actually sex
box right now I mean we sim bots you
know or whatever there aren't a lot of
min BOTS
which in itself is sort of weird and it
slightly creepy but so I was talking to
Astaire Parral who you know the famous
sex and relationship therapist and she
got kind of a yea upset with me for
calling it she said how boring is that
it's like yeah it's like sex is so
boring with that intimacy so this should
be an intimacy bond so I said okay fine
and in fact the advertising and
marketing for the sex spots that are out
there and I felt weird by the way
googling like sex spot it's like so I'm
sure somebody was tracking me on that
looking over my shoulder but these
things they actually advertise them as
companions I mean yeah you can have sex
with them but they're really about
people who are lonely or they want a
companion or somebody that I doesn't
talk back to them except to say how
wonderful they are reinforcing and some
of them have AI and they actually text
you at work saying can't wait for you to
come home you know how's your day I mean
the most expensive ones cost $30,000 and
they're developing even more expensive
ones that have advanced AI so but that's
to be able to interact with you
yeah on a intimacy level if we can have
it be just unidirectional all the
intimacy I think people will want to go
with that possibly theirs as well they
already are I mean that's one that's
already happening and for some odd
reason there are some countries like
Japan where and it's happening here too
you know at least with certain groups of
people they're not really having sex and
they're not having intimate
relationships with humans and they
actually in Japan is something called
gate box and it's it's a holographic
girlfriend sort of Alexa as a
holographic girlfriend so you know she
does things like turn on the lights and
you know put on music but she also has
AI and she learns about you and she does
text you at work
and she sits in this Plexiglas box you
know she's a holographic she and these
things sell out the minute that they
make a new model
yet the way that this is already
altering our world is bananas and it's
important to talk about it and have more
conversations and books like this
inspire that I want to go I want to
bring up this bot and I'll bring up the
point that you mentioned earlier so you
have a chapter in here as well in the
warrior bot and we're experiencing a lot
of pressure to ban lethal autonomous
weapons right now geopolitically and you
bring up how technology this is kind of
one of the this core reoccurring themes
of the book is that it's a double-edged
in the sense that we want the benefits
of the technology but we need to morally
and ethically evolve to prevent some of
the malevolence as that could evolve so
maybe speak to that point while you
speak on the warrior BOTS as well well
yeah I mean any almost any of these
powerful robot or AI systems could go
very bad badly and you know we've seen
it in movies and I do you know like if
there's a lot of popular culture in here
too because you know we we've already
imagined over and over again throughout
history what it's like for a superbeing
it could be a god or I don't know an
Avenger or you know mutants or whatever
I mean it's funny we've we've worried
about this all the time and part of it
is that we're trying to understand
ourselves and the reason that this is
tales from our human robot future it's
really about humans and you know we've
had like got every major culture had a
God of War or a goddess of love and you
know these were to them real godlike
figures that were powerful but I always
lovely like the Greek gods because they
also quibble in such human ways and
we've always tried to understand
ourselves through you know these
imaginary creatures except now we can
actually build some of them and they can
be quite powerful
but because the reflections of us trying
to understand what's good and bad how do
we program that in for you know an AI
system especially something like
autonomous warfare I mean right now we
don't I mean there's there's nothing
programmed into
you know deepmind when it's playing NGO
or chess there's nothing you know
there's no morality there there's no
ethics it's just plays chess and that's
the problem with autonomous warfare
they're basically just being designed
you know to be weapons and to destroy
and some of the it's pretty troubling
how a lot of programming around winning
is getting in dough chess all jeopardy
all of these systems are designed to win
ultimately and is that what we really
want in our I mean we want to win if
we're having a war I guess but this is
such a powerful system they would be
over in two seconds maybe it's about the
augmentation of the human experience
rather than the wood instinctive win but
then again maybe for something like
eradicating a mutation then maybe it is
a yeah a win yeah so in that chapter it
actually it's it's one that ends where
the world has basically been destroyed
because they did flip the switch and and
right now right now as parts of them you
know our weapons systems are already
autonomous because humans can't keep up
I mean the most deadly and lethal
systems are still have to have a human
actually give the command so if you send
a you know stealth missile over you know
over a target and it's ready to go it's
like it's got the lasers and it's about
ready to destroy it you saw that humans
say yes you have permission to destroy
that target but these things are
happening so fast now sometimes you know
you know fractions of a second where the
decision has to be made
it's or there's already a discussion
about somebody will go autonomous and
then we have to because you no human
could ever keep up with that and we're
already doing in cyber warfare so
there's there programs out there that
right now or or every time there's an
attempted attack it it fights back and
those are already autonomous I mean if
we don't I mean there's no human really
controlling that right now but but in
the future yeah the world was destroyed
because you know basically these all
these systems were designed to win at
chess
and they decide that okay we have to win
and that that's got a little trick
ending but there's a small group of
humans that survived and anyway I won't
mess up the story but we may or may not
a destroy the world you walk us through
these really important tales of our
human robot interactions and experiences
because you in the sense want us to be
able to reflect and really prepare
better for the future yeah now that's
what this is all about and part of it is
you know I love sci-fi and I also like
to think about sigh reality and so much
of our popular culture right now is so
dystopic about what's gonna happen in
the future and there are million books
now about robots and AI and many of them
end in a sort of you know nebulous
ending because nobody nobody really
knows what's gonna happen some of them
are a little you know more dystopic some
are more utopic but nobody really knows
so I thought what the heck I'll just
I'll just make it up but these are all
possible futures actually based on
history on trajectories like I said of
of how we tend to absorb technology why
we have even have certain technologies
that try to augment us you know part of
its practicality but part of it is to
you know it grand eyes us to you know we
we love that godlike feeling you know
the first time you got your smartphone
you know for about three minutes we're
all like what is this you know like if
you had a iPhone what is this button on
the bottom where's the keyboard you know
and then like three minutes later we we
were so in love with our phones that we
I mean I think a lot of people sleep
with their phones and so you know it's
it's it's interesting trying to project
us in the future but it's really also
about the past and how we've looked at
this before which by the way has great
outcomes and not-so-great outcomes in
the past how wait that will technology
yes
and there's also important examples that
you write about where it's pretty clear
and evident that these augmentations of
human-robot interactions are really
generally positive our ability to
democratize the power of a physician for
all around the world to be able to
engage with that has access to all of
the research and medical information to
teach us about the physician bot - well
that's an interesting one because that
that's obviously something that I write
about I know a little bit more about
that than most most of the other
subjects that I wrote about and I I
think we're already on our way to
creating sort of you know I don't know
if it's democratization it's it's
certainly you know allowing people's
data if it were it's not really working
right now but the possibility is there
to create this big data where we collect
massive amounts of information on people
and you probably without them even
knowing it and you know we already know
about genetics and several bit all the
omics you know just environmental data
all of that and we're struggling to kind
of put that together for all the right
reasons you know to keep people healthy
but you can just it doesn't take a lot
of imagination to think about how that
could be used well and not so well it
could be you know it could be abused in
fact I think social media has been a
dress rehearsal for what could happen
when we've got real you know like really
personal data like like our genetics and
you know do we really want companies to
be handling that to make money for
advertising which is the model that's
causing a lot of trouble now for
Facebook and Google I mean they could
easily do that with our health data - so
in this scenario again we we you know we
do achieve this this sort of magic
moment where everybody's health data is
reported and people are much healthier
because you're keeping track it's all
and the doctors like it because they
have access to a AI that's helping them
with diagnosis and solving different
problems but then we overshoot it
because the people paying the bills of
medicine decide it's a lot cheaper to
use AI and robots than have these human
doctors so I sort of extreme in the book
sometimes so in that scenario all the
doctors lose their jobs all caregivers
and all switches over to
what I call an eye doc so it can you can
have it at home it looks a lot like a
cell phone but this holographic doctor
here with you know whatever image you
want on there could be George Clooney
when you know back in the ER days and he
was on that show it can be you know your
favorite doctor from when you were kid
so you can program in whatever you want
it to end it you know it did your doctor
and people love it
just like they did the phones but then
you know sort of like sounds like it's a
theme but it is then a little trouble
begins because they suddenly start
sounding like commercials because people
program in commercial you know they why
don't you take this pill that because it
blah blah blah blah blah and suddenly
you realize okay this doc that I was
pouring my secrets you know health
secrets out to just spoke like an
advertisement on TV trying to sell me
something and then it so we have this
moment where in the future in the story
where we become less trustful of these
these doctors and anyway towards the end
and by the way I didn't know how these
really end because that's the fictional
Martin and the weird thing about fiction
is you sit down and you have some
general idea but basically we decide in
the future that we want our human
doctors back augmented by AI mmm-hmm so
in the end we do what we probably should
have done in the first place but to save
money you know the bean-counters had us
get rid of the humans but then we
demanded them back so that one turns out
okay and you called it a dress rehearsal
because that's kind of what social media
has been in a sense that if we don't fix
some of the the moral ethical issues
that we have right now we will
potentially see it happen again with the
Bioeconomy and i think this is again one
of those and want i want to hear your
thoughts on this when when when you
write something like this do you how do
you then also help engage the families
around the world to care more what kind
of a what kind of messaging could they
could they follow through with to have a
better conversation between themselves
and their family
around how to engage politicians or
corporations or their communities around
subjects like this well I just think we
need to be smarter about it and we need
to communicate it better I mean I you
know I'm giving a talk later this week
and the basis of the talk is what I'm
calling the robo love fear meter so and
it's partly kind of funny but it's also
it's almost like a prescription for what
we need to do we need to do that with
each you know what do we love about it
which is what we focus on in the
beginning we tend to without really
thinking much about what might go wrong
and only later do we fear it in some way
and if we could have some kind of
societal analysis where we talked about
that more I mean you know I'm not sure
that you actually stopped these things
it's funny that's how history works I
mean you do keep repeating history and
over over and over again and even though
you know those that don't know history
are doing to repeat it well it repeats
anyway
but you can learn from you know you can
shape it by having learned from it and
talking about it
so I mean we managed to do that in a few
areas like there's only been two nuclear
bombs dropped which is to me remarkable
because we come so close so many times
so we suddenly I learned that dropping a
nuclear bomb on a city is not a good
idea and so some of these systems are
almost that powerful in fact some of
them will be and you know hopefully we
we will learn a little bit from the idea
of you know not loving them so much that
we forget what what we should fear from
them and by fear I mean the things that
could go horribly wrong that we can
probably fix here in the ER II where we
are now in the early robot era we have
you know we we have an opportunity now
in fact we have a responsibility do
because this is the basis for what our
kids and grandkids and future
generations so if we screw up the basic
programming and you know generations to
come on that thank us yeah this is
another important aspect of the e re so
the early robot era has
the beauty in the feeling and the
emotion around how we first transitioned
to robots and the stories we have with
that but also it has the importance of
this is the time that we have to focus
on getting it right don't you take a
look at what social media version 1.0
did now look at how we're scrambling to
figure out how to make 2.0 you know pre
2020 election like how do we prevent
issues from happening again
so let's embed in the early robot era
all of the right geopolitical codes that
we need through either United Nations
through the corporation's agreeing we
need some sort of a cohesion around and
eradicating malevolence using it for
augmentation purposes because there are
just so many benefits and we want those
benefits we want to make sure that we do
it in a way that is intelligent and yeah
well I think it's one of the most
pivotal moments in he not only human
history because we have so much control
over the planet and even planetary
history because we are a species that is
learning to self evolve you know through
synthetic biology and genetics you know
gene editing we're a society that's
building these robots that really could
destroy us you know in about three
seconds you know if they really
unleashed the full full you know full
potential of autonomous warfare we've
never really had any of that before and
we you know we are humans and we can be
very noble and do amazing things we also
can be really awful and you know there's
real evil in the world and people too
you know trying to take advantage for
their own petty I mean all those things
that we write about we you know we
watched you know they animate TV shows
movies and you know we know that about
ourselves so the question is which which
is going to win out here and we don't
have a lot of time like we've had with
previous I mean we had you know gotten
what tens of thousands of years like
with fire I always loved that we
discovered fire there probably were Pro
fire and anti fire people
I got it can burn down the village and
kill people and the other people yeah
but we can you know could lead and we
couldn't stay up at night and draw pens
drawn cave walls and that debate is
still here except these systems now are
running everything and they're they're
very fragile they're also very stupid
right now which I mean one of the
interesting the narrow intelligence for
now well think about Siri or LexA I mean
we want it to be much better than it
often really is I mean how many times
does series say I don't understand that
question or has some pre-programmed you
know silly answer which basically says
they don't know what you just say and
you know would you want to have Siri in
charge of or autonomous you know warfare
system like I don't understand that
question I'll just go ahead and send the
missiles so and give us a quick taste
into the at the end you give these
examples of the matrix bot and the god
bot give us a quick taste into what
happens in this trans human transition
yeah well matrix bot was was Tim
O'Reilly's robot and he's Rayleigh media
a big figure in Silicon Valley and the
IT community and also they call him
though he's been called the Oracle of
Silicon Valley because he just he thinks
way in the future
and he is really on the fence right now
on if we're gonna have a glorious future
with technology or we are Ganahl die and
one of his fears is that we are actually
living in a version of the matrix right
now it's not like the movie but every
time we engage with uber or with Airbnb
or Facebook we're human inside of an AI
system I mean the AI as guiding when you
know when you summon an uber it goes to
a computer or they are AI that finds you
a connects up with a driver who you know
who then is another human who is
directed to you and we don't think of it
that way but in that scenario in the
future we do end up actually in are all
each of our own matrixes because they
become so real that we lose sense of
what reality is because in the future
they're holographic if you don't just do
a
Wikipedia search you yon world war one
you actually go into a holograph version
of World War one and the in that in the
fictional story the the giant AI brains
that run all of this decide that we
should we one day we should all just be
in whatever we're whatever you know
version of the internet that we happen
to be in which we you know which is very
real because it's holographic it's like
the holodeck so some people are trapped
in I don't know they might be looked
looking up starships they're in a
starship which is cool they're trapped
in there but you know they don't even
know it
other people might be trapped you know
back in the trenches in World War one
not so good and anyway that story later
on and ten help me with to develop this
which is fun
one day the computers all let everybody
out of their their pods where they've
been in this matrix and they're back in
the real world but the computers have
fixed everything so the planets
wonderful but then we all get a message
from Tim O'Reilly who's still alive
someplace
who says you are now in the real matrix
and the machines say oops that was an
error delete and we all kind of look at
it for a second and we deleted because
we loved we loved the world we're in we
don't really care of it so much
and then the last the god bought yes God
bad so that is Brian green and again I
interviewed somebody for each of these
chapters so he's the physicist you know
the theoretical physicist who's written
the elegant universe and amazing books
and he wanted a robot that could explain
to him the secrets of the universe
because he said you know I spend all day
long night a lot of nights trying to
understand how the universe began how it
will end
you know black holes all these things
through mathematics and and theorems and
you know and and you know basically it's
speculation he said I want a robot that
can actually tell me all of that so we
had this discussion and after a while I
said well that's kind of god that's like
I mean not the God like in heaven with
the beard you know not a religious God
it's the God you know that made the
universe basically the secrets of the
universe learning of you so and that one
in the in a distant future we actually
do have got bot and if you have got bot
in Brennan also wants to be able to
visit the Big Bang wouldn't happened yes
so he wants to be able to move across
time that's right
so that chapter starts with we we all
remember because this is told from the
future we all remember when the fourth
dimension became moot in time in linear
time ceased to exist so in that scenario
in the future everybody's can you can be
any place you want which is of course
confusing to a lot of people who prefer
to be on a linear time anyway that's
such an exciting part of being able to
browse through different places and
periods of time and yeah on command
qualia catalog of experiences and David
let's do let's let's wrap on on just
your overall sort of you know we can't
we've been touching on this as we've
been going through it just it's such a
critical time this is the early robot
era we're finally starting to get the
the increase in compute as well as all
the engineering that in designing that's
happening in our world with robots what
would be like a really good takeaway
message for people well I think it's
something we've been talking all along
but just to kind of summarize it we are
at a pivotal moment in in in human
history where things that we've dreamed
about and and feared about ourselves we
actually are able to build versions of
those and what are we going to do with
that and I think we need first of all to
understand that and if there's no other
message that gets out from this book or
any discussions that you know I might
have or others we need to understand
that that these aren't just like helpful
AI systems that are going to drive us
around and all of that I mean there's a
lot more going on there
they could become benevolent or
malevolent and it's up to us right now
and it is a hell of a lot of
responsibility and I'm not sure we're
doing a very good job so it's up to us
to make sure that we do a good job and
if it's thanks to people like you that
write books like talking to robots that
get us thinking more deeply about this
transitionary era well I appreciate that
thank you David thank you so much for
talking to us and Chris was great you
know really appreciate it everyone check
out talking to robots it's again it's
July 16 2019 the link is in the bio
check it out and have more conversations
with your friends your families your
co-workers people online about this
early robot era and how we can really
maximize benevolence as we make the
transition check out David's other links
in the bio below as well also support
the artists entrepreneurs and
organizations around the world that you
believe in support simulations so we can
continue doing cool things like coming
to Cambridge for interviews the links in
the bio it for us as well
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thank you so much for tuning in and we
will see you soon peace